[Music]
Germany is not only a very wealthy
country it's also a country famous for
running like clockwork and for producing
things of very high quality that at
least is the reputation if it's German
it's good
the fact is that over recent decades
Germany experienced one of the most
significant economic miracles in history
we've already told you about it both
here on visualpolitik and on our sister
Channel visual economic today Germany is
synonymous with high productivity
thriving companies and highly skilled
workers however it has one problem a
potentially very serious problem that we
have not yet told you about its
inability to attract skilled labor have
you ever considered going to work in
Germany I'm sure many of you have I have
but I'm sure many more of you have
thought about the UK the Netherlands
Canada Australia or the US first despite
being a very rich country with many jobs
and what appears to be the opportunity
to build great careers Germany does not
seem to be an attractive place for
highly skilled workers it ranks much
worse than the rest of its comparable
countries it has not reached the extreme
of Japan but it is an anomaly an anomaly
that would always be a problem but even
more so when you're working age
population is shrinking so the question
is why on Earth is Germany such an
unattractive destination for highly
qualified foreigners what could this
mean for what has traditionally been
considered the driver of Europe what is
the government doing to remedy this
situation well in this video we're going
to answer all these questions and who
knows maybe by the end of it you will
consider moving there or maybe not let's
get started
[Applause]
[Music]
dual politic viewers Germany is a top 10
country and by that I mean that it is
almost always among the top 10 countries
when we look at practically any index of
well-being and development GDP per
capita education levels productivity
levels access to basic Services
etc etc but its state-of-the-art
factories its modern educational
classrooms and it's more than enviable
annual investment in techno-industrial
development would be meaningless if
there were no teachers Engineers doctors
workers and professionals to put this
immense productive apparatus into
operation and the problem we can start
to see the problem perfectly in this
graph
according to official un figures the
German population will start to shrink
as of 2023. from a total population of
around 83 million people that it has at
present the forecast is for the 80
million Mark to be breached by 2047 and
to dip into the 70 Millions by the last
decade of this Century it is not as
dramatic a contraction as is expected in
countries such as Japan or South Korea
but it is still economically relevant
this data basically means not only less
population but also an aging population
and therefore much less available labor
[Music]
logically this is all in response to
changes in birth patterns but there is
something else that can also increase
the economic impact of this decline the
lack of talent retention yes Germany
receives a lot of immigration that's for
sure it's likely that many of you have
heard that however there is a problem in
this story every time a highly skilled
German worker retires it is not easy to
replace him or her because as we will
see in Germany there is no surplus of
immigration but above all there is no
surplus of skilled immigration so the
question is who could say no to the
German giant why are other destinations
preferred these are the questions we
have to find answers to in order to do
so the first thing of all has to be to
understand how we got here
[Music]
the first demographic Chimes
this is not an isolated case most
developed countries and also other not
so developed countries such as China and
Russia are experiencing an accelerated
process of demographic aging and take
note because this process not only
reduces the available labor force but
also considerably increases public
spending think about it pensions Health
Care dependents the fact is that Germany
understood the problem and guess what it
started to do its homework very early no
less than half a century ago
you see in the 1970s there was a turning
point in Germany its native population
began to shrink that is the country
entered a phase of negative population
growth as you can see since the 1970s
the number of deaths has exceeded the
number of births every year to
compensate for this Germany started to
boost immigration as you can see the
number of immigrants arriving each year
is generally greater than the native
loss of inhabitants this has allowed the
country to maintain its population
growth over the years
everything depends on the arrival of new
immigrants and if you look at the graph
you will see how at the beginning of the
21st century the first alarm was sounded
the arrival of immigrants plummeted at
the beginning of the 21st century almost
all of Europe was growing and growing
faster in Germany Germany was far from
being the only flower in an
ever-expanding Garden of prosperity and
that naturally had consequences
competition slowed down the influx of
new labor into German Industries the
question is what did they do the truth
is that the Germans took it very very
seriously the government knew how
important it was to attract young talent
and maintain demographic expansion in
order to prevent the economy and the
social security system from going into
crisis so to achieve their goals in
addition to actively promoting
immigration they also did things like
this check it out Germany's first
immigration law goes into effect
starting next year new immigrants will
be entitled to participate in
state-funded German language classes and
receive an introduction to the country's
legal system culture and history the
government has earmarked more than 200
million euros for the scheme the
measures worked
and the net number of immigrants
arriving in the country each year almost
tripled from 73 000 in 2004. the number
increased to 212 000 in 2008 and not
only that by 2016 one of the historical
ceilings in terms of immigrant
population was hit 432
000 non-germans moved to live in this
country of course Germany is part of the
European Union so what does that mean
that the country is subject to free
mobility of people and workers any of
the EU members can become a rival
country for labor a growing competition
that Germany does not seem to have been
able to manage very well
[Music]
but no danke
from 2013 onwards the influx of
immigrants to Germany started to slow
down again and even worse according to
oecd reports the country was becoming
less and less attractive for the arrival
of professionals because and this is
very important not all people are equal
logically from an economic point of view
qualifications count and that is why the
oecd issued this warning look at this
labor migration Germany is open to
graduates but immigration is difficult
for medium-skilled workers and why did
the oecd say this basically because of
this pay attention to the data Germany
is one of the oecd countries with the
lowest barriers to immigration for
highly skilled workers however the
number of immigrant workers from outside
the EU and the European free trade area
it receives is 2500 per year about 0.02
of the population the rate of skilled
immigrant workers received by Australia
Denmark Canada and the United Kingdom is
5 to 10 times higher oecd German labor
market report 2013. in other words it
was supposedly relatively easy to
emigrate to Germany but even so skilled
workers preferred and still prefer other
destinations whether because of the
language the standards or the lifestyle
the fact is that Germany is not a
popular destination
[Music]
of course that's not the whole story a
survey conducted by The swiss-based
International Institute for management
development found that German employees
perception of the ease of recruiting
International Talent was rather poor in
other words the oecd report did not
accurately reflect the entire reality it
seems that red tape has been a problem
for a decade now in some ways
legislation to retract skilled
immigration dating back to 2005 was
becoming obsolete compared to the
incentives on the table in neighboring
countries therefore between 2018 and
2020 the German Parliament started to
make several changes to the ACT changes
to make it easier for professionals from
outside the European Union for example
it was made easier for immigrants to
arrive without a contract however just
then the pandemic completely changed the
picture it brought the arrival of new
immigrants to a screeching halt
immigrants of all kinds skilled and
unskilled and that in the long run only
aggravated the problems
foreign
since 2013 the federal labor agency
itself has been monitoring what the
authorities refer to as bottleneck
occupations that is areas of the labor
market where job vacancies cannot be
filled by available workers in 2020 this
situation cooled down but since then the
trend has returned more and more areas
of the German economy are unable to get
the skilled workers they need in fact
this indicator is expected to break
records in 2023
the post-pandemic economic upturn
coupled with the growing demographic
aging is pushing the German labor market
into an increasingly critical context
while the demand for workers continues
to grow the number of immigrants
arriving each year has decreased not to
mention the number of skilled immigrants
to give you an idea about what we're
talking about according to estimates via
the German economic Institute in cologne
by mid-2022 there were already 1.5
million vacancies in this country a
figure that is expected to grow strongly
over the next few years the situation
has reached such an extent that some
commercial areas have had to start
providing their services on a reduced
basis and this in fact what explains new
stories like this Germany will use
temporary foreign workers to ease staff
shortages at German airports photos of
Travelers standing in Long lanes and
security checkpoints at Dusseldorf
airport earlier this week showed the
extent of the shortage in other words
the German economy is in urgent need of
Labor of all kinds according to
estimates by the German Institute for
labor market and employment research
search at least four hundred thousand
new arrivals are needed each year to
keep the workforce stable
[Music]
that's already a problem but
visualpolitik viewers the free skilled
labor thing that's already almost an
endangered species in this country
according to a survey conducted in
December 2022 7 out of 10 companies are
short of skilled labor not only that but
Germany is now facing another problem
it's no longer that few skilled workers
are arriving it's that many of the ones
they did have are leaving in other words
the country is suffering a brain drain
and that that is something that
endangers the formidable industry that
fuels Europe's greatest economic engine
but let's go back to the question we
asked at the beginning how on Earth is
it possible that there are almost no
professionals that want to live and work
in one of the most developed countries
in the world where is the problem well
listen up
[Music]
the three pillars of the talent drain
if we try to go straight to the heart of
the matter we could say that Germany
faces three major problems each of them
linked to the others for example first
of all the stock of human capital from
Europe cannot be expected to last
forever
foreign
[Music]
figures Serbia has lost nine percent of
its inhabitants in the last three
decades North Macedonia 10 Bosnia and
Herzegovina 24 and Albania 37 and
something very similar could be said
about Poland and the Baltic republics
among others all these countries have
lost a large proportion of their best
educated and most qualifying young
people and let's not forget Europe is a
very aging continent so the Paul of
skilled workers available for German
companies to recruit is limited
basically the pool of skilled workers is
no longer large enough
[Music]
along these lines many experts believe
that the initial effect of the EU
expansions has already come to an end
perhaps Ukraine was the only exception
but this country has also already
suffered a huge Exodus of skilled
workers particularly of young people for
this reason many analysts point out that
the search for talent must look Beyond
Continental borders and you know what
this is exactly what led to the 2020
reform of the skilled Immigration Act to
introduce more facilities for skilled
immigrants from third countries for
example University degrees were no
longer required but vocational training
was also accepted as proof of
qualification a demand that German
employers have been making for some time
why just take a look at this graph
of course this was not the only measure
some administrative formalities were
also reduced but the main stumbling
block was not solved which is none other
than this
the bureaucratic German immigration
system is extremely complex at least
seven Ministries are involved in the
process without taking into account
second-tier government agencies and
local governments to give just one
example the approval of a qualified
professional would involve the Federal
Ministry of economic Affairs and climate
action the ministry of labor and social
Affairs the Ministry of Education and
Research the ministry of food and
agriculture the Ministry of Health the
ministry of the interior and community
and the ministry of economic cooperation
and development so pretty
straightforward
[Music]
this obviously poses a major
disincentive for German companies in
2022 only 17 of the companies surveyed
by the bertels man Foundation recruited
skilled workers from abroad and while
large companies can hire consultancies
and law firms to speed up the process
smes face an almost insurmountable
barrier that is in a way the 2020
eligibility extension was a step in the
right direction to start attracting
professionals from outside the European
Union however it did not prepare the
bureaucracy for such a challenge
mobility within the common European blog
is much simpler but when you start
incorporating professionals from other
regions the documentation and
requirements multiply it is infinitely
more difficult and costly to incorporate
a tie or Uruguayan worker than a Polish
one this is the second problem and
finally the third major stumbling block
has to do with a much more complex
Factor the cultural one if only because
of the language
in August 2022 the German Federal
Employment Agency turned its attention
to this issue and do you know what it
found that most workers who arrive in
Germany without knowing German do not
even bother to try to learn it why
because they're already thinking of
leaving language integration problems
problems in obtaining permanent
residences housing costs cost of living
and taxes problems in reuniting the
family in the country and the clash with
the local culture are the most frequent
arguments given by skilled workers who
decide to leave Germany this is
something we have actually already told
you about on visual economic to make
matters worse the immigration
legislation clashes with a new type of
work that is practically ignored
Freelancers well these three problems
seem to explain why Germany is not as
attractive a country as it apparently
should be the question is is there a way
out what are German politicians doing
well we're going to take a look at that
right now
[Music]
retaking the job appeal
laughs
estimates by the German Ministry of
Labor suggest that if this situation is
not reversed by 2026 more than 200 000
jobs currently filled will become vacant
a situation that could have a very
negative impact on companies
productivity and the country's economic
growth therefore in October 2022 the
issue will be at the top of the public
agenda how Germany plans to attract
qualified foreigners reforms include the
introduction of a so-called opportunity
card that will entitle people to seek
work in Germany following a point system
based on language skills professional
experience and connection to Germany
among other criteria and finally on 29th
of March the qualified immigration law
was amended again foreigners with
adequate work experience and education
in their home country will be allowed to
work in Germany even if those
professional qualifications are not
recognized in Germany in addition they
will be allowed to work up to 20 hours
per week while looking for long-term
employment finally it will be possible
for persons in possession of academic
degrees or professional certificates to
remain in Germany for up to one year
while seeking employment will this new
reform work only time will tell the
question now is would you consider
living in Germany would you like to how
do you think this country could boost
the arrival of new Talent leave us your
answers in the comments and let's open a
debate and now if you found this video
interesting don't forget to give it a
like And subscribe to visualpolitik if
you haven't already done so all the best
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]